[Music]
so
apparently on june
[Music]
10th stavros from come town formerly
formerly of come town was on burke
chrysler show i don't know you know
brook chrysler's but this is really
funny joke about the machine
if dude if i think about this for a
second yeah if our patreon
was making a hundred and ten thousand
dollars a month which was what come down
wasn't it you'd be dead yeah i know
how could anybody walk away from that i
was if we [ __ ] despised each other
right you'd be like
especially considering we do five days a
week right
imagine doing
one day a week and banging out two shows
and making a hundred and ten thousand
dollars a month if you can't get in a
room or get on zoom
and bang out too low effort [ __ ]
two-hour shows for a hundred and ten
thousand dollars a month
people are like no they're going their
separate ways maybe stavros has a new
opportunity no there is some [ __ ]
bitterness or tension there is literally
nothing you can't do or nothing that's
taken away from you from doing a four
hours hours a day one day a week for a
hundred and ten thousand dollars that's
nothing
but sorry i i didn't mean to get off the
script no no it is on topic
this is related so this works so he was
on burke chrysler's show he's i'm sure
you heard his jokes fat guy no shirt oh
the guy yeah that uh yeah the fat guy he
likes to take his shirt off yeah yeah
yeah machine yeah machine here yeah the
story the story that he blatantly stole
from somebody do you mean the one he has
a painting of behind him on his show
cause he's a cringe factory can somebody
please in the chat one of you guys will
know and remember who did he take that
story from because that was a story that
he
borrowed i remember hearing borrowed
from somebody yeah
well
um
we've been talking about what you're
about to see here for a while and we
we've been
this really started bothering us
specifically marsh and then now i
noticed it so it started really bugging
me too because i never really paid
attention to it but when comedians refer
to themselves
anything other than
a normal guy
they call themselves
what do you say they call the people
civilians and they use phrases like nah
man he and i started in the clubs we
were in the trenches we were in the
trenches again in the trenches together
yeah so
brotherhood
um no no there's i'm telling you i know
we're family we're fatherhood the craft
so i started a little bit before but
just so we get a little build up i think
you're gonna love this since we're like
comic compliments yeah yeah they were
like well he is he's definitely a
[ __ ] comics comic because it's like
he's talking about nick by the way
like he's like we have a great me and
nick are so good at riffing together we
just this is 10 days before he announced
he was leaving we kind of like
there's like a yin and yang thing where
it's like you know
like like
we just kind of align on what we think
is funny and he he's like constantly
like his the way his brain works and the
way like what i provide community and
what he can provides just kind of align
so it's like no one knows like by the
way no mention of adam
not even a little men you know there's a
third guy on that show right
abilities better than me because we've
been doing you know the pod for years
together and he just he's just like
very quick i mean there's just like
you're just kind of like how does his
[ __ ] brain work that way and that's
where it starts here's for christ sure
and it's like you know it is funny
because like every comic all of us have
some kind of [ __ ] psychological issue
where your brain is just compensating
like we're all missing something and
it's like he just kind of has that like
he's like the f he's like the autistic
terminator where it's just like he puts
he puts a joke or a person in his sights
and he's gonna figure out
every little [ __ ] bit that you can
you can come out of that he's got a
great memory and it's like so it's great
it's so fun to riff with him yeah yeah
yeah but it's so funny a comic's brain
is so different than a pedestrian's
brain want to throw this in please
no no no no no not your stuff okay i
meant in his actual face i want to throw
this drink right now
but hey
i listen i always thought civilians was
insulting pedestrians pretty bad
pedestrian is infinitely more insulting
right
well
these people really think who the [ __ ]
they are and they believe it in their
soul and they and
you know it you could compare it a
little bit to streaming right we've been
to events where it's a lot of people
that are streamers that are coming of
course whatever and then you'll see some
of the other people that like there are
some people that really think
like yeah you know what i mean like oh
oh yeah ones
and then there's people here with
harrison smith but then there's people
like us that go everywhere and we're
like yeah i don't like any of these
people
i don't care like i like who i like and
i don't like half these people i like
having these people sometimes
sometimes they'll say things like yeah i
don't really care you want a bowl
dude how many times i've left these
events where were you like oh it's
hanging up actually and you just leave
to go hang out with some friends here
that are like auto mechanics to go smoke
a ball because she's like this sucks
these people [ __ ]
oh these [ __ ] i hate the pedestrian
brains well to be fair the comeback is
better out i bet every little [ __ ]
bit that you can you can come out of
that he's got a great memory and it's
like so it's great it's so fun to riff
with him yeah yeah yeah but it's so
funny a comic's brain is so different
than a than a pedestrian's brain and
like what you know like i can't help but
death stream is so funny by the way oh
am i saying that
i said i said to a woman
now he's getting laughed at and christ
just trying to you can see he's been
trying to push through it he doesn't let
him i said to a woman it's better than
civilian that drives me crazy it's like
we're not in the [ __ ] armed force
let's [ __ ]
thank you
this is [ __ ] thank you
this is why people have always
adored stavros halkias it's one of the
reasons i adore stavros he's never he's
never been a guy
that thinks that like anything about
status
or like stobs the one that most likely
is like most likely to be found hanging
out with fans like not even at a show
he's the one that's just
a laid back like stop taking this here
we're [ __ ] fat losers that just get
paid to be funny like don't take this
too seriously you gotta love that man
that overused that
yeah yeah says the guy who just said
pedestrians which to me thinks it still
feels worse
pedestrian still feels worse
because like civilian is this
where you're you're kind of taking
yourself and going like i'm special like
soldiers like a soldier yeah exactly
whereas pedestrian to me is almost
instead of upgrading yourself you're
downgrading other people because you're
like you peasants
you commoners that was so god so oh
it's like we are [ __ ]
so lucky we get to do this [ __ ] any
person on the street i respect more than
even my favorite comic
can i i agree with that sentiment yeah i
really believe that that's great yeah
stops [ __ ] greek trash from baltimore
yeah you know what i mean he doesn't
have any he doesn't put on any airs
oh really i couldn't tell
dude his tooth fell out i know and he
just left it and nick
for two years has been going get your
tooth fixed and he's like no and like he
was yelling at him like this is not a
gimmick this is not an image i don't
know what you're doing and now of course
he's selling a bunch of missing tooth
like he's crisp and
but like he didn't even bother getting
his tooth fixed he started going bald
and he said i'm growing the back out
like it's nice
so i can look like
a greasy greek diner owner with a
gambling problem
let's get that out there is that like we
we
give so much less to society than a
[ __ ] a janitor
[Laughter]
but i know you but like but there's a
reason we're doing it right
someone told me he goes yeah but you
know what we do we give that person
that's going through the hardest day of
their life we give them a moment of
reprise and i go yeah but we also send
people through the [ __ ] roof oh my
god
did this talk of of of
it's insane have you have you ever came
up this is no grip on reality
think of the greatest comics that have
ever lived like let's can you imagine
carlin
is calling right people that he's
talking to pedestrians or civilians like
he would never do that or think that
they're above them even if you do in
your mind think you're above people like
this is a [ __ ] shitty look right like
yeah we control their lives we can fix
them and we can break them we're gods
dude relax bert how many times have you
gotten an email or a dm or something
from somebody
that said hey man you know big fan
whatever you know a couple weeks a
couple months ago like i broke up with
my girlfriend and you know you guys show
is like you know one of the things that
really got me through it and you guys
are funny thanks
how like do you do you not like me
always get uncomfortable i don't i don't
know how to take that you know you go ah
stop i mean i thank you but
like i shouldn't be carrying anybody
either you know what i mean but like you
should be
i don't know there should be some
uncomfortableness with like oh i'm a
savior to these these people rely on me
like it's like ew
it's like shut the [ __ ] up i didn't just
come on and call people gay and [ __ ]
on the internet yeah i don't know man
it's it's this weird but they just buy
it they get they ascend to this weird
mental level where
oh yeah no just they really start going
i am like look at all these look at this
look at what i do for people i mean i
all i do is give
yeah well can you give me something
other than that machine joke that would
be great
people sometimes worse than anyone's
ever upset them in their [ __ ] lives
we never think about the flip side
yeah yeah we got that one guy that's
gotten through cancer that's he's like
oh thank god but you got that one black
chick who just stormed out oh you you've
ruined so many you got no i mean it's
amazing how you even make it through
carrying such weight on your shoulders i
i can't tell that said i'll go watch
this i just can't watch it it's this
he has stavon right yeah
and
sorry good
he just
this is how you can tell too that burke
horizon never listens to come down
doesn't know anything about stuff this
is when these people go like oh yeah i'm
just gonna have this person on because
they're getting buzz
and i need you know people on my show
doesn't do any research doesn't know
what stops capable of and then they just
mentally they always revert back to well
we'll just talk about the craft and it's
like
you know
stav does a really funny dundalk like
baltimore accent
stav is really good at riffing and
making fun of [ __ ]
um there's so much [ __ ] stop can do he's
great at crowd work he's like getting to
like big j levels as far as his crowd
work goes he doesn't look jewish like
but it's like there's so much you could
do with them and you come in and you're
like man we're so much better than these
pedestrian losers his crowd work is good
but is it brendan chob good
does he want to suck the dick of the guy
at the front at the front row for five
hours to stop us doing two and a half
minutes
can i suck your dick please yeah i mean
you know
but
again
can you can we agree with this
it tends to be
more la comics that have that mentality
than new york comics i'm not saying
there's not because there is of course
so many but
at least my interaction has always been
because new york comics justifiably so
hate themselves correct
and la comics hate themselves but they
see a therapist three days a week and
they're on like three different ssris
and they're learning how to love
themselves and that's the worst thing
you could possibly do if you want to be
funny is learn how to love yourself and
that's the problem that is really i
guarantee if you went took a [ __ ] wen
talked to 100 new york comics right now
and said what do you do to deal with
stress and anxiety and hot stuff they'd
be like i don't know man i do cocaine
and i smoke cigarettes i like okay when
you go to la they're like oh you know i
got this therapist i've been going to
actually he's uh he's uh uh god he's
bill burr's guy when he's out in l.a
anyway i've been seeing him right
that sounds like a real thing i mean and
like you know so he's been teaching me
that you know no no she has been
teaching me
i really gotta learn how to like you
know really like learn what my love
language is
you know just all this crap speak your
truth
i know and by the way if you want to
talk to 100 new york comics just sit
outside the stand for two hours they're
all going and out they're going in and
out all night oh and they all hate
themselves i know
um hey good set tonight yeah whatever
man i'll see you guys later
you